he's a full-time working Royal but
Prince Edward's responsibilities are
growing as he visited Kew Gardens with
the South African president legislation
moved a step closer to make him and
Princess Anne councilors of State the
question is that the house do now
resolve itself into a committee upon the
bills many of that women will say
content contrary not content the
contents habit
thank you
the change is simple but significant if
the Kings aren't well or abroad he needs
two councilors to represent him not for
standard visits like here
dodging chatty corgis but constitutional
duties these are members of the royal
family who can step in and exercise
the king's functions formally approving
decisions made by government and
Parliament and while the king is away
perhaps on an overseas tour so it
ensures that the wheels of government
and the wheels of parliament keep
turning
we saw this happen when Charles and
Prince William stood in for the queen at
the state opening of parliament the
problem for the king his counselors
include prince Andrew and Prince Harry
both no longer working Royals so adding
Anne currently in the Falklands and
Edward boosts his pool of stand-ins
some will see this as a snub to prince
Andrew and Prince Harry and although
they technically remain councilors of
State this move means for now they won't
be called to act as one I don't think
I'm going to write an essay so while no
one's excluded Prince Edward and
Princess Anne are promoted the King has
acted quickly fast-tracked legislation
means it should be law within a couple
of weeks Laura bundock Sky News Kew
Gardens